ugh
huh
isn't that gene seems she's talking to
someone
let's let her finish then go say hi
which is what has brought us to this
point in the first place
if you are unable to promptly deal with
the storm terror threat
then leave the defense of monsta to the
foot we can put an
end to monsters dragon issues all we
need to do is bring
monster yes what's your point
uh i'd expect a more professional
attitude from your diplomats
yeah here you are saying you want to put
an end to one of the
i won't have any of this nonsense in
front of the knights of fevonian
it's not as correct fine that's enough
negotiation for today
at this stage it's simply an amicable
exchange of can i'll be sure to make
oh you're back thanks for your help the
aftermath of storm terrors
however the pressure from the delegation
has become
too big to be ignored delegation
from leo harbor or in azuma city
they choose to follow the god of cryo
their envoys go by a particular name
the fatoui heard of them oh them
they're super famous
wait infamous is more the word
i don't think killing storm terror is
the right course of action
the cryogods fatoui have always coveted
the animo god's power
i don't believe they have monstat's best
interests at heart
what is it oh
let us head back to headquarters then we
shouldn't discuss important matters
out in the open
are considered the same in status
monstat is independent and does not
belong to any other nation
in fact despite being referred to as a
city monsta is a nation
though fatoui are known to be the most
aggressive diplomats into that
makes sense given the tone of that woman
just now
so rude
it's a crystal embedded with some kind
of power
lisa are you able to analyze it
let me take a look hmm
i can see impurities in the crystal but
upon further inspection no
i'm sorry i can't make a proper analysis
at the moment
give me some time i'll take a look
through the library's restricted section
right i'll leave the research to you
then lisa
understood i'll notify you all if i make
any progress
so i wouldn't go getting your hopes up
they're incredibly ancient texts
not to mention ouch gosh that hurt the
impurities in the crystal ah
i see the impurities and the elemental
energy we embody repel each other
it's strange though you have elemental
abilities as well
but don't seem to be affected in the
same way
anyway the crystal would be better left
in the hands of my cutie
it will just be a pain if left with us
both literally
fascinating do you know anything about
i do not know what well then the knights
of fivonius have another favor to ask of
you
please accept the title of honorary
knight
and the gratitude of the acting grand
master
honorary night of vavonius
we ask for your continued assistance in
finding some answers
storm terrors rage and strange crystals
may the wind open your we'll meet back
here if you find anything
you